Aaron's in Virginia our sons do not have
credit cards they use a debit card from
a checking account
we've been told they need to get credit
cards and carry a low balance to get
good credit
they don't want credit cards how are
they ever going to buy a house without
building credit it's a shame you can't
even build good credit by paying your
credit cards off every month how should
we advise them well Karen I think you
have the wrong goal for your sons you
are teaching them or you believe they
seem to have their act together but you
believe that they their best shortest
path to prosperity is a hike or the only
way you get a high five go score is you
borrow money and you pay it back why so
that you have the opportunity to borrow
money and you can pay it back why so
that you have the opportunity to borrow
money and you can pay it back why so
that you get a high credit score why so
that you have the opportunity to borrow
money and pay it back a 750 780 credit
score cost you somewhere around $100,000
in interest
that's a dumb but goal lady I wouldn't
want my kids to have that as their goal
why do you want anybody to build their
credit it's a freaking dog chasing its
tail there's no data that says using a
credit card causes you to become wealthy
as a matter of fact there's a lot of
data that says otherwise
why in the world would you want your kid
to smoke pot part of the time that's
dumber than a rock no they ever there if
they've got it figured out now can you
get a mortgage without having a credit
score or having in quotes stupidly built
your credit yes you can pay your
landlord earlier on time have a
reasonable down payment be steady on
your job for two years and the mortgage
company can if they know how like
churchill mortgage does can do manual
underwriting
which means they actually do
underwriting instead of just looking at
one number and going who make the loan
who a monkey can make a FICO loan and so
that's what the problem is with mortgage
industry it's gotten dumbed down to this
level so no your kids got it figured out
tell them to go to Churchill with no
credit score never having borrowed money
in their entire lives when they get
ready to buy a house and they'll be
ready to go don't worship at the altar
of the great FICO
Oh FICO you are the provider of all good
things we bring you offerings of
interest we bring your gold card to you
FICO and we set it at your feet
FICO thank you for letting me fleece my
car and pay an effective rate of
fourteen point two two percent Thank You
FICO you are the provider of all good
things great and small Thank You FICO
this is the typical American in their
stupid worship mode stop it ridiculous